how's it go friends my name is today
we're gonna play with the useless
website.com it's basically a website
what it says take me to another useless
website please and it will take you to a
useless website let's begin
[Music]
okay let's try it
it's my channel really really funny
[Music]
alright another one that is a pug
licking how cute still better than my
channel
it's my ad passive-aggressive password
machine please enter a password I love
ass may God have mercy on your email
account your nips are huge so close I
mean because I care what you're so
[ __ ] me that'll do Pig that'll do
sssss yeah like you're going to remember
this could you please shut the [ __ ] up
and let me talk damn it oh my god what
the that's a lot of [ __ ] blue balls I
can't but my new homepage right there so
good can i no damn it
yeah grandpa no clothes calm my favorite
I go over there every day
[Music]
can I please uninstall the internet now
cat bounce calm there are cats panting I
can flick them up to space space cats I
should call it their mother Monty Python
or some [ __ ] I mean these need some
pretty good dubstep to it Qualis to the
max calm
there's no koalas Oh what oh god it
keeps going it keeps going it keeps
going had it had it how does it work oh
my god is there giant penis koala gonna
appear oh my god I see it do you see
your browse and wonder if I didn't want
to actually spend the time to do all of
them that's not gonna be me I has a
bucket calm I has a bucket no they boo
stealing my bucket damn it try not to
laugh I love you like a fat lady love
apples what that doesn't make any sense
Oh God
[Music]
why would fat ladies love what was that
how many apples are there in these
titties
I think it's expand it's expanding all
the chance that chance I dropped it
never again
[Music]
this is my new homepage definitely giant
batch farts come
oh god I'm scared I was that yeah
[ __ ] hell man
[Music]
0:08 but it's how you don't one it's
like the kind of website you if you get
drunk or high you just spent hours on
the Selma's man i think they're changing
color my pointer pointer calm so finds
my pointer yep you'll never get me over
here
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] you need to stop
pointing no I don't like it shut up you
son of a [ __ ] stop oh my god I'm done
I'm done
you win rid Ridley diddly dad
[Music]
that could be my new my new homepage oh
my god oh this place to say this is my
new homepage
this is the greatest website I've seen
my love big tax but yeah but kippers we
did it we found the best website on the
internet and the most use lived the best
most useless website on their name
fantastic
hope you enjoyed whatever the [ __ ] this
was thank you thank you for leaving a
like and hit him subscribe to become a
bro cuz if you ain't a bro you're not a
problem okay thank you guys for watching
I'll see Bros in the next video and as
always remember stay
you